vous détendre lebrun tranquille depuis
quelques années le dr george honos
s'intéressent davantage au sommeil de
ses patients comme cardiologue j'ai
chargé mon habitude et au même titre que
le tabac je pense toujours la question
sur le sommeil pourquoi parce que les
années de sommeil et devenir facteur
important de crédible et voici qu'une
nouvelle étude menée auprès de 4000
espagnol confirme le lien entre le
manque de sommeil et l'athérosclérose
une maladie qui provoque la formation de
plaques de lipides bloquant
éventuellement les artères les personnes
qui dorment moins de six heures par nuit
sont 27% que susceptibles de souffrir de
cette maladie
comparativement à celles ayant dormi
plus de sept heures et cette étude
rejoint les préoccupations du chercheur
angelo tremblay de l'université laval
intéressé par l'impact du sommeil sur
l'obésité et la santé cardiovasculaire
ils nous permettent quand même avec leur
technologie ces chercheurs de démontrer
que le petit dormeur et plus à risque
d'avoir des plaques d'athérosclérose sur
les artères un peu partout dans le corps
tous les sujets de l'étude portait un
appareil pour mesurer le sommeil donc
c'est pas au tour apporté ces mesures et
ça c'est énorme comme différence et
l'autre chose c'est que les auteurs ont
fait 10 des sites et scan des artères
coronaires
c'est vraiment de l'imagerie médicale
fiable une étude qui devrait réveiller
tout le monde et mettre l'emphase sur
les bonnes habitudes de sommeil
6 heures mais deux fois quatre heures ça
l'est parce que a rod de mon travail
le défend son billet de faire des heures
supplémentaires je pense que les gens se
rendent compte qu'ils sont fonctionnels
quand ils donnent pas de vision se
rendre compte de l'impact sur leur
mémoire l'apprentissage extrême et sur
les maladies sur les choses à long terme
je pense que peu de gens seuls mais le
manque de sommeil c'est un peu comme le
stress
même en sachant que c'est mauvais pour
la santé
il est parfois difficile de passer à
côté ici à louise despatie radio canada
montréal